foreign  country music star Kelsey ballerini is  putting her heart first addressing  rumors that she's dating outer Bank star  Chase Stokes I know I know I know I know  I know I know stop reading stop reading  stop looking  but what this happened  taking to Tick-Tock the singer pointed  to a post made by gossip site dimwa that  claimed her and Chase Stokes were an  item  what what  what  no let's not do this you know  oh  the romance rumors began when Chase  posted a series of photos to his  Instagram including a pretty cuddly  photo with Kelsey taking out the college  football national championship earlier  this month  [Music]  [Applause]  while there was no confirming or denying  the rumors this comes just under five  months since ballerini and fellow  country singer Morgan Evans announced  their divorce after five years of  marriage